the Emmy award-winning actor and author
of if I understood you what I have this
look on my face thrilled to have right
here on the Rich Eisen show set alan
alda good to see you good to see you
thank you thank you for for coming here
why write this book I'm keen to know but
and learn whatever I can from you about
communicating since what I know living
of eight years ago I started helping
train scientists and doctors to
communicate better because I found out
that I had something to contribute when
I was doing the science program on PBS
for 11 or 12 years and when I had found
was if you can get them to be more
personal and to deliver their stories
and tell a story about their work then
those of us in the public will
understand the better will understand
about our health better from the doctors
and will take the doctor's advice more
and what I understood was if you teach
them improvising this is weird isn't it
you teach them improvising a doctor to
improve doctors and improvisation don't
usually go together Alan I know well but
if you know maybe he'll fix your liver
maybe he won't
are they right no the idea is it's not
it's not that to be funny or to just do
things unexpectedly it's the basis of
this kind of improvising is to make you
help you make contact with the person
you're talking to and to really get in
sync with them and when that happens
then the doctor shows empathy towards
the patient for instance right and when
when the patient rates the doctor is
empathic they're 19% more likely to
follow the doctor's advice that that
sounds like it must be life-saving and
at least some of those cases well in
terms of you connecting with science and
doctors is that borne out of playing one
on television not in all that people
assume that but I was interested in
science for a long time no one from the
time I was a kid and when I got to do
the science show which is great because
I I got to spend the day with scientists
and find out about their work but what I
found out while we were teaching them
over the eight years we thought about
8,000 scientists
and doctors in eight years and what I
realized was it applies to everybody
people husbands and wives bosses and
employees salespeople and that's when I
realized I ought to write a book about
it because I it could make a
contribution to how people relate to one
another so there was no suggestion to a
doctor to build a still and make alcohol
when you're in your tent or anything
like that based on your experience if I
tried my day away from doctors who do
that yes that was just a TV show okay
here's where I go I keep hearing you
know how many people I've met we say
that they are the person that Hawkeye
was based on tell me where they know
somebody who is it must be thirty people
who think that they're Hawkeye maybe
they are in some malgal nation I don't
know well I mean I guess that's that
that's a credit to you making him
somebody that they feel that they could
have empathized with also could be it
could because I am so terrific at that
if you are Alan I mean you've written a
book about relating and communicating so
but I think it's more that there were a
lot of guys like that who just preserved
their sanity or acted crazy in chasing
skirts and stuff like that so growing up
on the East Coast and in a spot like New
Jersey I mean it's sort of a football
crazed spot did you ever try figured out
like just figure it out to play football
before you got it no no I in a game of
touch football I got armed in my throat
couldn't speak for the rest of the day
so that's it that was my football career
until I made paper lion right where I
played Plimpton that I think you were
talking about yes and I told the
producer before we started the movie
about the touch football game and he
said well at least we know what league
you're in it wasn't too sure he's going
to be able to do the movie because I
didn't have much experience if I did
when I was in the junior high school I
ran the wrong way with the football what
do you mean you ran wrong what happened
I caught the ball and ran toward my own
goalpost
did you score for the other team and no
they stopped and my team stopped me
before I got there wrong way
right but when I made the movie I worked
out and I tried to do my best and I took
lessons from football players and we're
always making a movie with the Detroit
Lions and I actually got to the point
where I could I could throw the ball 50
yards Wow and hit the receiver that's
significant yeah but I can only do it
once a day and then I had to sleep with
an ice pack
but you could at least at one point
spotter receiver in any way in 50 yards
down the field kind of amazing that is
amazing
yeah so when you were on I'm with Alan
Alda here on the Richards at you when
you were on that set I mean it was
basically you Lauren Hutton and a bunch
of real-life football players and yeah
and Vince Lombardi that he was just in
one scene I didn't spend much time with
him but I did spend time with Alex
Karras and John Gordy and that they were
wonderful to be with very funny guys
Alex Karras became an accomplished actor
well I mean he was in Blazing Saddles he
had one of them were you know iconic
scenes in blazing and victor/victoria he
gave really good performances and on the
football field he can like - I don't
know he was like an automatic kicking
machine what do you mean well at one
point as a joke 11 guys piled on top of
me this to them was funny 11 Detroit
Lions yeah on top of them and each one
weighed about eight million pounds hmm
so Alex was the one closest to me and he
kept going like this with his foot into
my ankle kidding yeah I don't think he
meant to he just it's like something you
do when you're on top of somebody like a
knee-jerk reaction yeah yeah and my foot
went to sleep and it didn't wake up for
a half an hour and you're able to get
back you know when he punched in blazing
Saddles when he punched that animal in
the head yes I don't I think that was a
real animal of agree [ __ ] could really
throw the right cross yeah named the
character s IRA [ __ ] was his name for
sure I am Alan Alda here on the Rich
Eisen show I'd like to take a 60-second
break come back talk more about your
book and
about the if you wouldn't mind the
popularity of mash and the fact that it
still stands the test of time in terms
of how many people have watched that
episode and it even beats some Super
Bowls and I'd like to talk with you
about that sure Alan Alda the author of
if I understood you would I have this
look on my face here and the Rich Eisen
show in person back with Alan Alda in 60
seconds
[Music]
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show Alan
Alda here on the program you said you
hadn't thought are these paper line
stories in quite some time right to know
what you think we would have an
impression on you think I'd wake up
screaming every night
yeah because Alex Karras is kicking you
in the leg but the fact that you're able
to laugh about it is if I may borrow a
lot of yours it's comedy equals tragedy
plus time right yeah that's that's
probably true from that was from crimes
and misdemeanors of yeah what the hell
okay I love that movie I think that's
such a good move which is your favorite
movie that you've been I don't have a
favorite I don't even think about them
after I do them really yeah I just gone
on to the next thing when was the last
time you watched an episode of mash now
a whole episode that sometimes I see it
when I'm going past that dial but I
don't I don't remember when the last
time was really it's been I mean I'm
proud of it but I just in the past
so you're just working and obviously you
move on yeah but it's been it's just
remarkable I have a list that we're
going to put up for our viewers here the
top-20 most watched television shows of
all time 19 of them are Super Bowls and
still sitting in the top ten number nine
was the series finale of mash which you
wrote and directed and acted in a
hundred and five point nine million
people watch that which is about seven
more than Super Bowl 43 and at anymore
people don't know million seven more
million but I mean what do you think of
when you see that mash is still you know
I it it's hard to understand and we
didn't know at the time how how popular
the show really was when we when when
the last episode was on the air just
before it was aired we were watching it
on a big screen at the studio then we
went out to dinner to celebrate on the
way to the restaurant we realized that
the streets were empty and that's when
it occurred to me that most people or
half the country was home watching our
show at the same time it was an amazing
experience
why do you think people were so
connected with
that shows you no idea book about
communicating you there are obvious
elements like there was good writing
good direct and good acting but I think
I think people always sensed that the
show was at its heart about people who
had really lived through a horrific
experience of war and as funny as the
show was that's no laughing matter and I
think they could feel with the people
who would lived through that experience
why did you stick with it as long as you
did when others I'll show that because I
thought it I thought we were doing good
work and and as like when I thought that
we were starting to run out of steam I
suggested that we stop what did the
bosses think about that they said why do
you want to stop I love it
right right but I I wanted I wanted this
to always be proud of what we did and
that bring the last drop out of it
before you know for we should Alan Alda
here on the Rich Eisen show so you wrote
this book about the art and science of
relating and communicating if you could
boil it down for whomever if they're out
there trying to figure out from somebody
who's been there and done that in all
manners of communicating yes what do you
think is is something that just I think
I've found is that you can't communicate
you can't make your point with another
person or talk to a crowd or write for
them unless you're thinking about what
they're going through as you try to make
your point with them as you try to
explain something to them or get them to
understand something that you believe is
important hmm unless you're thinking
about what they're going through while
you try to communicate this stuff you're
just making up a message and spraying it
at them how do you know if it's landing
and so the book is about a lot of
different ways to make contact with
people and read their minds by getting
clues from their body language from
their voice and that kind of thing is
this part of the reason why you've been
married to the same woman since 1957 our
even good it's very day well we've been
married 50 years 60 years
gee ten years went by like that is
varied 60 years and people say how come
you're married so long and my wife says
the secret to a long marriage is a short
memory I love that I've never heard that
one again well that's her thing should I
try that on the façades with my I've
just got my Gisela by my 14th what we
came through one for a regular baby you
are that's I am NOT yeah 14 yeah well
congratulations you just you just had
that anniversary just did Jonesy's
anniversary yeah it's the ivory
anniversary so I got my wife half a
piano yeah and I got a 44 keys that's
what I got yeah thank you series go on
to say say I'm so gullible no see but
I'm communicating with you you are and
you're making real contact with me I
mean I see you really watching me so
okay you must be no wonder you got this
big show here you must be really good
communica light Ryu no it's what I find
in all honesty for having this
conversation
it's and I learned this from watching
people like Carson and Letterman
and Jon Stewart Charlie Rose who has a
testimony on the back of your know clear
low to you right is that listening yeah
is the toughest form of communicating
the most important thing and the person
trying to communicate is the one who has
to listen the best you have to listen to
the person you're trying to communicate
with will get a good estimate of out
there how they're getting when you I was
watching you guys yell about sports
because well we were we were or more
conversing in a demonstrative way we
might put it but that would say
screaming okay okay
so what I was really wondering was when
when you engage like that are you aware
of even though you're passionate about
what you have to say are you taking in
what they're saying are you well I know
I am I turn to the guys with whom I was
conversing were you taking in what I was
saying yeah yeah and I disagree with it
but it doesn't mean I'm not listening
yeah that's that's that's nice that's
how it ought to be otherwise did you
notice only one person respond notice
that while the other two are sleep
see that's the jersey guy let me ask you
something yes Alan whatever we've been
talking doesn't sort of interested in
this and especially with the experience
of the Detroit Lions behind me this
business of reading another person I get
the impression that that's important in
sports to have kind of a high degree
well I mean when you're playing against
somebody not just running or something
like well there's different forms of
communicating just in football alone for
instance I have been you know I've been
fortunate to my other gig at the NFL
Network where they would refer to this
as my other gig but that I work with
Hall of Fame athletes who are Hall of
Fame defenders Deion Sanders being one
of them and he would tell based on a
wide receiver how he stood whether a run
or a pass was coming well because and on
other defensive linemen would know that
based on the pressure of watching how
the offensive lineman placed his hand on
the ground and you could see could be
could held in that detail yes so there's
different forms of communication body
language and verbal for instance and
then obviously coaching needing to read
the other individual is right but that's
all I know what's interesting is that I
guess taken for granted in sport you've
got to really be aware of the slights
movement the way the head is going and
like and the rest of the bottom as its
that way and acting too well but that's
that's how I got to understand what I
think I understand about communication
was my experience on the stage you've
got to relate to the other person so
well that you can tell you can pick up a
sensation from them a vibe from them in
a way that's so clear to you because
you're observing their bodies and their
voice is such an acute degree that that
changes you it makes you respond to them
with the next line not because the next
line is in the script but because
they're making you say it and it's I
think it's a little like tracking the
other player in a in a game and that's
what I
I think we have to do when we
communicate we have to track each other
in the same way well not to get too deep
but since we're there it just seems that
a lot of people aren't communicating
with each other these days Alan it seems
worse than ever yeah and it's not so hot
because I think partly it's that we hear
what we want to hear the Internet has
made it easy for us to be in that bubble
or the echo chamber the other things
that they've called it and it's kind of
important to do what we were talking
about before to listen to what the other
person says even if you don't agree
because it's a good idea for us to test
our assumptions this on all sides of the
political spectrum the book is called if
I understood you what I have this look
on my face Alan Alda you are a treasure
sir and I'm thrilled that I could look
you in the face and communicate that
with honesty I think it too well and
honestly you're somebody who came into
my household
since I could remember watching
television and like I said for the
television audience in the radio you you
responded to a fan mail that letter that
my dad was an inveterate letter sender
mostly to Airlines to complain oh they
ever respond all they did back in the
day when they actually did that sort of
thing instead of dragging people out of
planes they actually responded by by
letter and you responded that was a big
thrill for all of us and it's been a
thrill having you here so fine coming
ahead and talking with you terrific you
bet that's Alan Alda here on the Rich
Eisen show so Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you like
that download our app please just if
it's a memory thing just delete other
apps you don't need those apps this app
the Rich Eisen show app you need that